Smart people freeze when insulted, then
feel terrible about it. This isn't
weakness. It's neuroscience.
Your brain thinks someone criticizing
you is the same as being attacked by a
predator. Your amydala floods you with
stress hormones. Logical thinking goes
offline, and you freeze like a deer in
headlights. The smarter you are, the
more you'll replay this moment. Your
intelligence becomes a weapon against
itself.
But here's the game changer. The
difference between a panic pause and a
power pause is intention. Next time
someone insults you, try this. Count
slowly to four while maintaining eye
contact. Feel your feet on the ground.
Take one deep breath. You're not frozen.
You're choosing to think. Most people
will interpret your pause as confidence,
not confusion. Confident people don't
rush to defend themselves. Your freeze
response was never weakness. It was just
untrained strength waiting for the right
techniques.